avant que la vidéo ne commence j'ai une
question à vous poser vous croyez
vraiment que les gens ont lu tous les
livres dont il parle bien sûr que non
sinon on ne pourrait pas parler de grand
chose
et oui il y à 24 heures dans une journée
et il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le chien
donc le secret de la culture générale ce
n'est pas de lire des livres c'est quoi
alors et bien en fait il n'ya pas un
seul secret il y en a cinq les étudiants
et les personnes les plus cultivés les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets savez vous avez lu
renan comme moi mais il se garde bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent et à développer rapidement
et facilement leur culture générale
parce que leur rapport au savoir a
changé et une fois qu'ils les appliquent
les cinq secrets ils comprennent toutes
les références des personnes cultivées
ils savent s'exprimer avec profondeur
sur n'importe quel sujet ils brillent
par leur culture dans les conversations
c'est dans les débats et ils ont le
recul nécessaire pour faire preuve
d'esprit critique ça vous intéresse et
bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets et
je vous explique comment les appliquer
dès aujourd'hui pour vous cultivez 10
fois plus rapidement sans vous prendre
la tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant haut à droite de la vidéo
soit qu'ils ont sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo c'est
l'histoire de 10 secondes donc faites le
maintenant et vous pourrez découvrir le
premier secret qui vous attendra bien au
chaud dans votre boîte mail après avoir
regardé cette vidéo voila voila je vous
ai dit ce que je voulais vous dire je
vous laisse regarder la vidéo et moi je
vais promener aristote
[Musique]
première référence de l'esprit des lois
montesquieu pourquoi commencer par
montesquieu parce qu'ils passent
notamment avec cet ouvrage pour un
précurseur voir pour le fondateur de la
sociologie après c'est vrai qu'il a été
beaucoup de choses vous le connaissez
certainement comme un des plus célèbres
philosophes des lumières avec voltaire
rousseau et diderot la tradition
académique française ne sait pas trop où
le ranger homme de lettres théoricien
politique historien du droit idéologues
qui a préparé la révolution française
kane sdi lui et que montesquieu et je
cite le plus grand économiste français
et il le compare à adam smith dans la
préface de la théorie générale on range
donc pas spontanément montesquieu dans
le champ intellectuel de la sociologie
qu'on peut définir comme à l'étude de la
société et des phénomènes sociaux à
partir de leurs propriétés propres et il
ya des raisons évidentes à cela le mot
sociologie n'existait pas à l'époque
montesquieu parle d'une société révolue
pas de la société industrielle dans
laquelle naîtra la sociologie en tant
que discipline académique et enfin il se
sert des idées de la philosophie
politique
et pourtant sa démarche dans de l'esprit
des lois et bien sociologique il
identifie les causes profondes qui
explique l'évolution générale des
sociétés puis il regroupe la grande
diversité de loi et demeurent ce qu'ils
observent dans le monde dans quelques
catégories et il fait ça sent le jargon
sociologique qui donnera des maux de
tête aux lecteurs des futurs sociologue
professionnels
le style de montesquieu est très
agréable ces phrases sont simples il
suit une logique démonstrative il
élimine le superflu pour aller à
l'essentiel pour bien écrire disait-il
il faut sauter les idées intermédiaire
assez pour n'être pas ennuyeux pas trop
de peur de n'être pas entendues en clair
il ya un équilibre à trouver entre le
laconisme et l'exhaustivité voilà un
auteur qui pense à son lecteur
maintenant quelles sont les idées les
idées proprement sociologique
intéressante dans de l'esprit des lois
il ya pas mal de choses différentes dans
ce livre sa cohérence laisse à désirer
mais on peut grosso modo le découper en
trois thèmes sociologique premier thème
la théorie des trois types de
gouvernement deuxième thème les causes
physiques de l'évolution de la société
et troisième et dernier thème les causes
morales de l'évolution des règles de la
société les règles sont les moeurs les
coutumes et les lois je vais vous
résumer ce que montesquieu dit
d'intéressant à propos de chaque thème
sa théorie des trois types de
gouvernement est inspiré de la théorie
de la politique d'aristote qui était la
référence dominante de la philosophie
politique classique voici les éléments
que vous pouvez en retenir il y a trois
types de gouvernement la république la
monarchie et le despotisme donc
montesquieu oppose fondamentalement les
gouvernements modérés la république et
la monarchie et les gouvernements non
modéré le despotisme autres éléments que
vous pouvez retenir la république c'est
lorsque le corps social détient la
souveraineté la monarchie lorsqu'un seul
détient la souveraineté et qu'il exerce
dans le cadre de règles et enfin le
despotisme c'est lorsqu'un seul détient
la souveraineté mais qu'il ne l'exercent
pas dans le cadre de règles pour
montesquieu chaque type de régime se
caractérise par un sentiment dominant
dans les relations entre les individus
le dévouement à la collectivité dans la
république l'honneur dans la monarchie
et enfin la crainte dans le despotisme
enfin dernier élément vous pouvez
retenir montesquieu précise que plus la
société est grande plus l'autorité doit
être despotique la dimension de la
société et donc un paramètre important à
prendre en compte pour choisir le type
de gouvernement adapté c'est en parlant
des types de gouvernement que
montesquieu parle de la séparation des
pouvoirs mais je ne vais pas développer
cette idée parce qu'elles relèvent
davantage de la science politique sur le
plan proprement sociologique cette idée
signifie qu'il faut rechercher
l'équilibré des puissances sociales pour
que les hommes soient libres on peut le
dire plus simplement en disant que la
concurrence des élus garantit la liberté
des individus si vous voulez en savoir
plus sur l'idée de la séparation des
pouvoirs de montesquieu à les lire ma
synthèse sur le site mille idées de
culture générale le lien est dans la
description de cette vidéo je passe
maintenant au thème de l' influence des
causes physiques sur la société
montesquieu pense que le milieu
géographique
influencer les institutions mais pas qui
les engendre nécessairement autrement
dit le milieu géographique est un
facteur important mais seulement un
facteur il ne fait qu orienter les
institutions dans une certaine direction
l'idée la plus importante de ce thème
c'est que le climat froid ou chaud
modéré ou extrêmes le climat favorise
une certaine manière d'être pour monter
ce que par exemple les gens recherchent
plus les plaisirs dans les pays chauds
et moins dans les pays froids à climat
différent société probablement
différente donc montesquieu évoque
également les facteurs de la fertilité
des terrains et de la démographie
je passe maintenant au dernier thème
sociologique l'influencent des causes
morales sur les règles qui existent dans
la société qu'il s'agisse des moeurs des
coutumes ou des lois
la distinction entre ces trois types de
règles est une idée capitale du thème
voici la différence fondamentale les
moeurs sont des règles implicites
imposée par la société comme diront les
sociologues et ses règles dicte la
conduite intérieure de l'homme par
exemple la fidélité au conjoint fait
partie de ce qu'on appelle les bonnes
moeurs dans la plupart des sociétés
ensuite les coutumes sont elles aussi
des règles implicites mais contrairement
aux moeurs elle dicte la conduite
extérieur de l'homme par exemple la
poignée de main pour dire bonjour est
une coutume dans les sociétés
occidentales
enfin les lois sont des règles formuler
explicitement donc imposée par l'état et
elles servent à dicter la conduite
extérieur du citoyen par exemple
l'obligation de porter la ceinture de
sécurité en voiture est une loi en
france elle date de 973 pour ce qui est
du conducteur
montesquieu avance que ces trois types
de règles réflète ce qu'il appelle
l'esprit général d'une nation c'est à
dire la manière d'être d'agir de penser
et de sentir d'une collectivité
particulières telles que l'on fait la
géographie et l'histoire ce concept
d'esprit général c'est un peu ce qu'est
la culture pour les anthropologues
américains c'est-à-dire l'ensemble des
productions de l'esprit et des valeurs
d'un groupe humain ce concept montre
bien que montesquieu à une perspective
sociologique la société est un tout un
ensemble qui doit être étudié en tant
que tel
deuxième référence cours de philosophie
positive
auguste comte
qu'est ce que cette référence fait dans
ma liste vous pouvez déjà être sceptique
parce qu'il y a le mot philosophie dans
le titre ce qui semble indiquer que
c'est un livre de philosophie et non pas
de sociologie vous pouvez être d'autant
plus sceptiques qu'auguste comptes n'a
presque pas une influence en sociologie
et on s'est même plutôt moquer de lui
parce qu'il a élaboré des plans précis
de ses rêves avec par exemple le nombre
d'hommes de chaque site et les fonctions
de chacun et les détails de la
hiérarchie sociale et pourtant le cours
de philosophie positive fonde
véritablement la sociologie en tant que
science pourquoi parce qu auguste comte
il posé clairement la priorité du tout
sûr l'élément en l'occurrence de la
société sur l'individu et la nécessité
de comprendre l'élément à partir du tout
on retrouve bien là l'ambition qui
définit la sociologie étudier la société
comme un tout qui a ses propriétés
propres comptes arrive à cette nouvelle
perspective intellectuelle en partant
d'une autre science la biologie quand on
cherche à comprendre un organe on ne
peut pas le faire sans considérer l'être
vivant en entier et bien c'est pareil
pour comprendre l'être humain on ne peut
pas le faire sans en considérer le
groupe humain dans son ensemble une
autre raison pour laquelle le cours de
philosophie positive mérite d'être
considéré comme une référence de
sociologie c'est que compte
contrairement à montesquieu parle de la
société indus riel qui émerge à son
époque il s'intéresse donc et déjà aux
mutations sociales auxquelles à
réfléchir on les premiers sociologue
professionnels sur la forme le cours de
philosophie positive est un livre très
long il y a six tomes c'est qu'ils
représentent environ 3500 pages et bien
sûr personne ne lit la totalité de ses
3500 pages c'est pourquoi le livre n'est
à ma connaissance pas disponible en
version papier en plus d'être très long
il est désagréable à lire le style de
compte est lourd ces phrases sont
longues et les répétitions fatigue le
lecteur personne ne lui a expliqué qu'il
faut user des adjectifs et des adverbes
avec parcimonie que retenir de cette
référence sur le fond maintenant la
teste sur logique fondamentale d'auguste
compte et que toute société tient par
l'accord des esprits cela veut dire que
les hommes ne peuvent s'assembler que
dans la mesure où ils partagent les
mêmes croyances ça doit vous rappeler le
concept de réalité imaginaire si vous
avez lu le best-seller sapiens mais
auguste comte n'est pas le premier à
dire que la vie collective se construit
sur des conventions c'est une idée très
ancienne une fois qu'on a mis en
évidence le fait que toute société tient
à voir l'accord des esprits on doit se
demander comment cet accord évolue-t-il
en reconstituant le progrès du savoir
scientifique auguste comte met en
évidence la loi qui préside à
l'évolution des mentalités la loi des
trois états en premier lieu l'esprit
humain opérette à l'état théologique
caractéristiques du moyen-âge et de
l'ancien régime dans cet état la
réflexion est focalisée sur la recherche
de l'essence de l'univers et les hommes
pensent que c'est dieu qui causent les
bouleversements sociaux
l'esprit humain serait ensuite passer à
l'étape métaphysique caractéristique de
l'esprit des lumières et des
encyclopédistes où s'épanouissent les
croyance en des entités ou des
abstractions le contrat social de
rousseau par exemple enfin l'esprit
humain parvient à l'état dit positif ou
scientifiques à partir duquel il renonce
à trouver l'essence du réel pour se
borner à rechercher les seules lois de
la nature
l'adjectif positif
s'opposent à hypothétique et il qualifie
ce qui repose sur les faits
fondamentalement il sait a signalé un
idéal de fiabilité supérieure pour le
savoir par opposition au savoir
théologique et métaphysique qui n'était
pas le produit de la méthode
scientifique moderne cher à auguste
comte qui était polytechnicien cette
façon de pensée dite positive qui a
triomphé en mathématiques en astronomie
en physique en chimie et en biologie
cette façon de penser doit selon compte
s'imposer finalement en matière de
politique et aboutir à la constitution
d'une science positive de la société la
sociologie la manière dont je comprends
cette idée c'est que la science moderne
a transformé la philosophie politique en
sociologie une autre idée intéressante
et plus précise c'est que le triomphe de
la mentalité positive change les
fonctions et donc la hiérarchie dans la
société les savants vont remplacer les
prêtres et les industriels au sens large
les hommes de guerre nouvelle société
nouvelle élite je termine avec une
petite anecdote après le livre dont je
vous ai parlé le cours de philosophie
positive auguste comte donnera à sa
théorie la dimension d'une religion
qu'il appellera la religion de
l'humanité il imaginera que la mentalité
positive
issu de la maturité des sciences il
imaginera que cette mentalité unira
l'humanité autour des mêmes dogmes
scientifique et la dimension anecdotique
de ce prolongement théorique c'est qui
lui aurait été inspiré par son aventure
très platonique avec une jeune femme 17
ans plus jeune que lui et fervente
catholique clotilde de vaud comme
l'avait reconnu compte lui même le
sentiment est le seul vrai moteur de
l'action
troisième référence de la démocratie en
amérique
tocqueville pourquoi ce livre est-il
dans ma liste parce que c'est l'analyse
de référence dans l'histoire de la
pensée occidentale de la société
démocratique certes tocqueville n'est
pas considéré comme un inspirateur de la
pensée sociologique d'ailleurs c'est
pendant mes études de philosophie à la
sorbonne il ya de cela une dizaine
d'années que j'ai découvert de la
démocratie en amérique mais cette
analyse de la société démocratique est
véritablement sociologique dans la
mesure où la perspective intellectuelle
et aux listes tocqueville réfléchie du
point de vue de la société prise comme
un tout comme un ensemble irréductible à
ces partis sont ni des centrales est
révélatrice de la dimension sociologique
du livre la démocratie n'est pas un
régime politique un certain type de
pouvoir c'est un certain type de société
la perspective intellectuelle est
également originale pour deux autres
raisons c'est un français magistrats
dans un vieux pays donc qui parle de
l'amérique une jeune nation où il a
voyagé tocqueville y avait été envoyé
par le gouvernement français pour
enquêter sur le système carcéral
américain il seconde raison c'est un
aristocrate issu d'une vieille famille
de la noblesse de normandie qui parle de
la démocratie en clair tocqueville et
culturellement très étranger à la
société qu'il analyse c'est peut-être
cette extériorité qui lui a permis
d'être si pénétrant que dire de la
démocratie en amérique sur la forme
l'essai est divisée en deux livres le
premier avait été publiée en 1835 le
second en 1840 au total il y en a pour
1000 pages mais c'est 1000 pages sont
très lisibles par rapport au livre des
futurs sociologue professionnels
tocqueville était soucieux de son style
et il le travail est en suivant l'idéal
d'éloquence du français classique qui
combine la simplicité est ce qu'on
appelle le naturel son effort de clarté
se décèle aussi sur le plan de
l'organisation du propos il traite une
idée à la fois on peut donc dire que la
forme du livre et démocratique dans la
mesure où elles auront le fonds
accessibles au plus grand nombre quoi
retenir du fonds maintenant
pour commencer la matière des deux tomes
est un peu différente le premier tome
analyse la démocratie américaine de
manière descriptive le second élargit la
perspective en montrant comment la
démocratie change la société civile
l'idée centrale de de la démocratie en
amérique encore une fois c'est que la
démocratie n'est pas seulement un régime
politique mais plus fondamentalement une
nouvelle société où les relations entre
les hommes sont animés par des valeurs
différentes et la valeur cardinale de
cette nouvelle société c'est l'égalité
l'égalité des conditions est la
caractéristique majeure de la démocratie
américaine ce n'est pas seulement un
idéal un principe politique et juridique
c'est la passion la valeur suprême des
américains c'est leur mentalité ils
voient le monde et conçoivent leurs
tâches droits et devoirs dans ce monde
sous le prisme de légalité démocratique
tocqueville en déduit que la société
démocratique se définie du point de vue
sociologique par l'égalisation des
conditions cela signifie qu'il n'ya pas
de différence héréditaire de conditions
et que toutes les occupations toutes les
professions toutes les dignités tous les
honneurs sont accessibles à tous en
termes d'évolution sociale il n'y a pas
seulement une égalisation des fortunes
mais aussi une égalisation des
intelligences tocqueville l'aristocrate
voit bien la médiocrité qui caractérise
la civilisation démocratique
en résumé la société démocratique à deux
dimensions sociologiques l'égalité
théorique des opportunités et la
tendance pratique à l'uniformité des
niveaux et des modes de vie une
conséquences sociologiques importante de
l'égalisation des conditions c'est
qu'elle change la dynamique de
l'ensemble social elle rapproche la
grande majorité des citoyens parce
qu'ils partagent les mêmes valeurs et
aspirent au même chose combinée à la
règle de la majorité au coeur du
fonctionnement des régimes démocratiques
elles risquent alors de donner naissance
à ce que tocqueville appelle une
tyrannie de la majorité l'homme
démocratique temps à se rallier
spontanément à la vie du plus grand
nombre voir à ne plus tolérer les
opinions minoritaires
l'idée de la tyrannie de majorité montre
que le problème fondamental de la
société démocratique et la compatibilité
de l'égalité et de la liberté la source
de la tension entre ces deux valeurs et
le développement de l'individualisme
chacun avec sa famille tente à ciseler
des autres et donc à négliger ses
devoirs de citoyen or en démocratie
cette tendance au repli est une menace
pour la liberté car la liberté est
préservée par l'intérêt du citoyen pour
les affaires publiques et par sa
participation effective
mais en amérique ce risque est limité
par la vie associative les américains
multiplient les organisations
volontaires les gens qui ont des
intérêts communs se réunissent pour
discuter pragmatiquement des problèmes
qui se posent à la société les citoyens
s'impliquent donc dans les affaires
collectives à l'échelle locale
en conclusion tocqueville voit la
liberté offerte par la société
démocratique américaine surtout comme le
fruit de la mentalité des américains une
mentalité qui combinent à l'amour de la
liberté et la fois en comparaison la
société française de son époque et
déchiré par l'opposition entre l'église
et la démocratie c'est à dire entre la
religion et la liberté
4e référence les premiers principes
herbert spencer cette référence est
importante parce que c'est la source
intellectuelle de ce qu'on appelle le
darwinisme social comme le nom l'indiqué
il s'agit de la transposition de la
fameuse théorie de darwin en sociologie
la thèse est que la société s'organise
fondamentalement par la sélection
naturelle et à long terme l'espèce
humaine s améliorerait en éliminant les
individus les moins adaptés à son milieu
de vie mais le propos des premiers
principes dépasse le cadre de la
sociologie spencer et offre sur près de
600 pages une théorie générale de
l'univers du cosmos à la morale en
passant par l'éducation et le principe
universel qui lui permet de tout
comprendre c'est l'évolution
cette théorie a eu une énorme influence
non seulement en angleterre spencer est
un sociologue anglais mais aussi en
europe aux états unis et même jusqu'au
japon spencer était probablement
l'intellectuel européen le plus célèbre
dans les dernières décennies du neuvième
siècle comme beaucoup de monde je l' ai
découvert en lisant le roman martin eden
de jack london qui avait lu les premiers
principes de spencer et qui en était fan
c'est une oeuvre capitale du 19e siècle
mais elle a perdu son crédit le siècle
suivant depuis le darwinisme social est
perçu comme une justification de
l'inégalité et il est associé dans
l'opinion publique à l'eugénisme nazi
sur la forme le livre est difficile
d'accès il faut se taper des normes
paragraphe la plupart des phrases sont
longues et le style est un peu pompeux
après c'est plus lisible que beaucoup de
sociologues du xxème siècle dans la
mesure où il y a peu de jargon mais bon
ce n'est quand même pas une partie de
plaisir pour ce qui est du fond je ne
vais pas vous résumer tout le propos du
livre parce que ça n'a pas d'intérêt
pour votre culture générale
donc je vais me concentrer sur la
théorie du darwinisme social de herbert
spencer quelles sont les idées
essentielles de cette théorie
spencer affirme que l'évolution de la
société obéit à une double logique une
logique d'intégration et une logique de
différenciation d'une part la société
progresse d'une forme moins cohérente à
une forme plus cohérente comme
l'illustrent leur rassemblement de
familles nomades en société de plus
grande taille ou encore le passage sur
le plan technologique de petits outils
rudimentaires à des machines grandes et
complexes d'autre part la société évolue
en allant de l'homogène al hétérogènes
si la société était au départ un agrégat
d'individus quasi identique elle a
évolué par étapes
les hommes se sont spécialisés dans des
fonctions puis des usagers des règles
sont apparus enfin la société s'est
divisée en différentes classes une autre
idée importante du livre c'est que
spencer voit la société comme un
organisme vivant il en déduit qu'elle
essuie des lois similaires dont tout
particulièrement la sélection naturelle
cela signifie que les modifications
survenues chez les individus du fait de
la logique de différenciation ne peuvent
être durables qu'à la condition qu'elle
soit adaptée au milieu sinon les
individus meurent et les modifications
disparaissent avec eux ainsi la thèse
fondamentale du darwinisme social de
spencer et que la vie social s'apparente
à une compétition une compétition où les
éléments victorieuse et dominateur
permettre à l'espèce humaine de toujours
progresser vers une meilleure adaptation
au milieu dans cette perspective le
malheur et la misère des individus les
plus faibles qui sont les perdants de la
concurrence sociale le malheur et la
misère se justifie par le destin global
de l'espèce humaine décrit par spencer
comme un élan vers la perfection
5e référence le capital karl marx je
pense que vous vous doutez de la raison
pour laquelle se livrait dans ma liste
le capital qui est l'oeuvre la plus
importante de marx le capital et
l'analyse sociologique de référence de
la société capitaliste c'est à dire la
société dont le régime économique est
fondé sur la propriété privée des moyens
de production comme les ouvrages
précédents celui-ci n'est pas non plus
connu comme un ouvrage de sociologie
c'est vrai qu'il recèle des idées de
différentes natures certains disent que
c'est un texte d'économie scientifique
d'autres que c'est de la philosophie
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que marc se
propose entre autres choses une analyse
sociologique de la société capitaliste
son analyse relève de ce qu'on peut
appeler de la sociologie économique car
elle part du principe que les phénomènes
sociaux sont essentiellement déterminé
par la manière dont la société créée
réparti les ressources le capital de
marx dépasse bien sûr toutes les autres
références de ma liste par son influence
historique il a inspiré des projets
révolutionnaires radicaux et il a
carrément accouché de société d'un genre
nouveau notamment l'urss et la chine
maoïste parallèlement il a conservé un
prestige théorique important au sein de
la communauté savante internationale il
est dans beaucoup de programmes
universitaires
si jamais vous souhaité le lire en
entier prenez des vacances parce que
vous en avez pour plus de deux mille
deux cents pages réparties sur deux
tomes et puis le propos du capital et
moyennement accessible pour l'honnête
homme d'un côté marx est un théoricien
profond qui emploie du vocabulaire
technique si bien qu'il ya des
développements difficile à suivre de
l'autre côté il est également capable de
la clarté d'un historien ou d'un
journaliste et il a le sens de la
formule
de telle sorte que certains passages
sont à ghallab la lire bref ce n'est pas
une partie de plaisir mais il ya pire
sur le fond maintenant comment la
société capitaliste fonctionne tel
d'après marx son point de départ est que
la société est déterminée par sa
structure économique
les rapports entre les gens la vie
politique et la vie intellectuelle toute
la réalité manifeste de la société
découle d'une réalité profonde la
manière dont la société produit est
réparti les ressources et plus
particulièrement pour marx qui écrit à
l'époque de la révolution industrielle
la manière dont sont produits les biens
matériels la base économique de la
société et ce qu'il appelle
l'infrastructure et ce qui est bâti sur
l'infrastructure c'est la super
structure c'est à dire pour marx les
institutions et les façons de penser une
fois qu'on a compris cette distinction
on doit logiquement se concentrer sur ce
qui est fondamental dans l'évolution
sociale
l'infrastructure or la dimension
essentielle de l'infrastructure de la
société industrielle c'est qu'elle
oppose deux classes sociales d'un côté
les entrepreneurs capitalistes qui
possède les moyens de production les
machines à l'époque et de l'autre les
prolétaires qui se définissent par le
fait qu'ils ne sont pas propriétaires
des moyens de production ce qui les
contraint à vendre leur force de travail
marx est bien conscient qu'il existe
d'autres classes sociales mais il
affirme que les deux classes qui ont un
destin historique la bourgeoisie et le
prolétariat absorbe progressivement
toutes les autres d'un point de vue
sociologique la société capitaliste se
caractérise donc par le fait que
l'ensemble social se subdivise de plus
en plus radicalement en deux sous
ensembles antagonistes une autre
dimension essentielle de
l'infrastructure de la société
industrielle séquelles qu'auront les
relations sociales c'est-à-dire les
interactions entre les éléments au sein
du tout social dans une société
capitaliste
les hommes ne se comportent plus les uns
à l'égard des autres de la même manière
que dans une société traditionnelle
comme l'essence du capitalisme et le
désir d'enrichissement certains
individus en exploite d'autres il s'est
même là pour marx la véritable origine
du profit
les relations sociales change même plus
profondément elles sont déshumanisés par
l'argent un échange humain entre
guillemets consiste à échanger
directement ou indirectement une
marchandise contre une autre marchandise
c'est à dire que le but est la
satisfaction mutuelle des besoins mais
comme l'argent est devenu une fin en soi
dans la société capitaliste tout échange
est désormais un échange d'argent à
argent c'est à dire un échange animé par
le désir sous jacent de réaliser un
profit tout ce dont je viens de vous
parler l'antagonisme bourgeoisie pour
l'état ria et la corruption des
relations sociales cela mais bien
évidemment à mal l'harmonie de la
société dans son ensemble
inévitablement ça va mal finir selon
marx il prédit plus précisément que la
société capitaliste va aider en cela par
la révolution s'autodétruire et ainsi
donné naissance à une nouvelle société
or ce sera une société inédite dans la
mesure où il s'agira de la première
société de l'histoire dépourvu
d'antagonisme il n'y aura plus de
classes sociales plus de tensions entre
groupes aux intérêts divergents la
cohésion sociale sera parfaite ce qui
paraît bien utopique
6e référence le suicide émile dürckheim
longtemps méconnu et ignorer cette
référence est devenu un classique de la
sociologie parce que c'est la première
application de la méthode des 1000
dürckheim l'un des fondateurs de la
discipline qui était aussi le chef de
file de l'école française de sociologie
qu il avait défini ses principes
méthodologiques deux ans plus tôt dans
l'essai au titre peu sexy les règles de
la méthode sociologique
le suicide est également une référence
importante plus généralement dans
l'histoire de la pensée parce qu'elle a
révolutionné la perspective
intellectuelle sur le phénomène du
suicide en effet dürckheim affirme que
ce phénomène c'est lucide en réalité
dans le cadre de la société et non pas
comme la manifestation d'un tempérament
individuel sur la forme le livre est
plus lisible que beaucoup d'autres essai
de sociologie mais c'est quand même à
ried j'avais commencé à le lire il ya
une dizaine d'années mais il m'était
tombé des mains a tellement il ya le
tableau et de statistiques honnêtement
un siècle plus tard la démonstration ne
sert à rien seuls comptent les idées
essentielles quelles sont-elles
dürckheim fait tout d'abord un constat
les statistiques montrent qu'on retrouve
le suicide dans la plupart des sociétés
et qu'au sein de chaque société les taux
de suicide sont relativement stables en
france par exemple le taux est compris
entre dix et vingt suicides pour 100
mille habitants depuis les années 2000
et les variations sont effectivement
très légère d'une année sur l'autre ce
constat inspira dürckheim l'hypothèse
fondamentale du livre à savoir que le
suicide est un phénomène social
à ses yeux c'est là la seule manière de
comprendre comment l'instinct
fondamental de survie de l'être humain
pourtant si puissant peut être tu la
fragilité psychologique de l'individu
entre certes en ligne de compte mais ce
n'est pas un facteur qui permet de
prédire le passage à l'acte
le facteur vraiment déterminant est le
degré d'intégration de l'individu dans
le groupe dans les faits une
collectivité qui compte beaucoup
d'individus solidaire et cohérente une
telle collectivité relit ses membres les
uns aux autres de telle sorte qu'ils se
protègent les uns les autres de
commettre l'irréparable
dans le détail dürckheim distingue
quatre types de suicide premier type le
suicide égoïste causée par une
intégration insuffisante de l'individu
il se retire dès lors de la vie par
excès d'individualisme
deuxième type de suicide le suicide
altruiste
lorsque l'individu est tellement fondu
dans le groupe qu'il est capable de
sacrifier sa vie pour les valeurs
collectives qui l'animent par exemple
dans les sociétés primitives ou chez les
militaires
troisième type de suicide le suicide est
dix anomique qui manifeste un état
individuel de frustration extrême que la
collectivité n'a pas réussi à apaiser et
enfin quatrième et dernier type de
suisse le suicide est dix fataliste
c'est le suicide de l'individu qui a
perdu espoir comme l'indiquent le nom
ces quatre types de suicides existe dans
tout groupe suffisamment large ce qui
varie ce sont la fréquence général du
suicide est la fréquence d'un type de
suicides particulier la perspective
sociologique de dürckheim lui permet de
comprendre pourquoi les taux de suicide
sont plus élevés dans les sociétés
développées que dans les sociétés
traditionnelles
approximativement trois à quatre fois
plus élevé ce n'est pas de turckheim
c'est moi qui ai trouvé cette estimation
voici l'explication comme les sociétés
modernes fondée sur la division du
travail et les différences d'individu
elle favorise l'isolément de l'homme le
collectif ne procure plus de cadre
psychologique à l'individu cela décuple
la probabilité de passage à l'acte dans
un suicide de type égoïste
7e référence théorie de la classe de
loisirs thorstein veblen
pourquoi cette référence est elle
importante en sociologie parce qu'elle
met en évidence et la dimension
psychologique des rapports de classe
pour le dire simplement la société est
divisée en sous groupes qui rivalise et
se jalousent voici ce que dit raymond
aron dans la préface du livre l'oeuvre
de thorstein veblen apprend à discerner
au delà de l'accoutumance à la vie
quotidienne la comédie humaine la
rivalité puéril des adultes en quête
d'argent de gloire et de prestige jamais
capable d'atteindre un but qui fuit à
mesure qu'ils en approche puisque ce but
se définit non pas en soi mais par
rapport aux conquêtes des autres veblen
est un observateur particulièrement
lucide de la comédie humaine pour parler
comme aaron parce qu'il n'est pas né
dans le milieu qu'il analyse issu d'une
famille rurale d'immigrés norvégiens il
a découvert les société bourgeoise du
début du xxème siècle en enseignant dans
les meilleures universités américaines à
chicago à standford à new york
université qui surtout à l'époque ne
sont pas une place forte du prolétariat
il a 42 ans quand il écrit son
chef-d'oeuvre la théorie de la classe de
loisirs
1899 qu'en dire sur la forme je les lui
en école de commerce il ya donc une
dizaine d'années parce qu'un professeur
de marketing en avait parlé et je garde
de ma lecture un souvenir contrasté d'un
côté j'avais bien aimé le pragmatisme
typiquement américain le propos est
accessible le style simple pour un
universitaire et les exemples abondent
de l'autre côté j'avais trouvé que
verlaine s'éternise et que la
démonstration est froide qu'en retenir
sur le fond maintenant
pour commencer il faut expliquer ce
qu'est la classe de loisirs le concept
du titre comme son nom l'indiqué cette
classe sociale se définit par le fait
qu'elle ne travaille pas elle se
distingue de la classe laborieuse qui
elle se déshonore par le travail cette
idée qu'elle se fait de cette
supériorité correspond au modèle grec du
loisir ce que les romains appelleront au
siom qui signifie le loisir par
opposition aux négociants le travail le
commerce
fondamentalement la valeurs qui guident
la classe de loisirs c'est l'honneur
veblen estiment que la classe de loisirs
année avec l'institution de la propriété
individuelle parce que la propriété et
permet de donner une preuve durable de
l'honneur naturellement l'institution de
la propriété a excité la concurrence
pour la richesse et pour l'honneur
la société industrielle à radicaliser le
phénomène la propriété est désormais la
seule et unique preuve d' estime sociale
ce qui nourrit un désir de richesse
infinie
la caractéristique la plus importante de
la classe de loisirs et que c'est elle
qui règle la concurrence sociale
c'est elle qui définit pour la société
toute entière ce qui est honorable et ce
qui ne l'est pas c'est elle qui
détermine le mode de vie qu'ils méritent
considération
c'est encore elle qui fixe les normes de
consommation de toutes les classes
on a rivalisé majeurs devaient blaine
celle que j'ai découverte en cours de
marketing la consommation ostentatoire
l'idée c'est que la classe de loisirs se
distingue notamment en ne consommant pas
de la même main dire que les autres
classes dans les sociétés industrielles
de la fin du 19e siècle les gens
ordinaires qui sont pour la plupart des
ouvriers et des paysans consomment des
biens et des services par l'utilitarisme
c'est à dire pour satisfaire un besoin
la classe de loisirs elle consomme pour
donner la preuve d'où l'adjectif
ostentatoire elle consomme pour donner
la preuve de sa capacité financière et
plus particulièrement du fait qu'elle
n'a pas besoin de travailler les membres
de cette classe sont prêts à payer un
prix disproportionné
par rapport à l'utilité du bien ou du
service parce que cette disproportion
est une preuve éclatante de leur
supériorité sociale c'est la logique
psychologique est derrière l'attrait
pour le luxe
cette logique explique un paradoxe
économique qui a été baptisé l'effet
veblen la demande pour certains produits
augmentent lorsque le prix augmente
alors que selon la loi de l'offre et de
la demande moins de gens achètent un
produit s'il devient plus cher
comment expliquer cet effet et bien
l'augmentation du prix peut augmenter le
gain de statut associés aux produits ou
au service de nouveaux consommateurs
désirent le produit plus cher parce
qu'ils y trouvent désormais un bénéfice
social l'idée de la consommation
ostentatoire est importante en
sociologie parce qu elle inspirera
d'autres théories sur la dimension
psychologique des rapports de classe par
exemple l'analyse des mécanismes de
reproduction des hiérarchies sociales de
bourdieu ou l'analyse de la société de
consommation de baudrillard
8e référence philosophie de l'art jean
georges sim elle se livre est important
parce que c'est l'analyse sociologique
de référence de l'argent et je dis bien
sociologique parce que l'argent est la
monnaie sont bien sûr abondamment
analysé en économie george simmons lui
laisse l'économie c'est-à-dire à l'étude
de la création et de la répartition de
la valeur il laisse cette dimension de
côté pour se concentrer sur les
dimensions psychologiques et
sociologiques de l'argent ce choix
s'explique peut-être par sa situation
personnelle comme son père lui a laissé
un énorme héritage il n'a pas besoin
donc n'y ait de l'argent son
indépendance économique explique
peut-être aussi son indépendance
intellectuelle s'y mêlent est un
sociologue atypique sur le fond comme
sur la forme il est aussi philosophe de
formation il n'hésite pas à mélanger des
idées de différentes disciplines ni à
s'opposer aux théories dominantes si les
étudiants et l'élite intellectuelle de
berlin l'aiment beaucoup les
universitaires n'apprécie pas sa liberté
intellectuelle mais il est considéré
aujourd'hui plus de cent ans après sa
mort comme l'un des plus grands
sociologue allemand classique et son
oeuvre est étudiée et commentés dans le
monde entier sa philosophie de l'argent
est un pavé de presque 700 pages après
le propos est plutôt accessible il est
certes abstrait puisque c'est de la
théorie mais le style est relativement
simple et décontractée étant donné la
profondeur des idées la lecture est
également facilitée par le fait que si
mais la répète en les reformulant ses
grands thèmes quoi retenir sur le fond
maintenant l'idée essentielle est que
l'argent est une force civilisatrice qui
concentrent en elle toutes les valeurs
et qui permet ainsi à l'individu de
mieux comprendre le monde pour commencer
georges sim elle considère que la
propagation et la prise d'ampleur de la
monnaie différencie nettement le monde
moderne du monde féodal elles ont
instauré par tous la médiation de
l'argent dans les relations d'homme à
objets comme dans les relations d'homme
à homme par la rémunération par la
cotisation et c'est le niveau
d'abstraction requis par la médiation de
l'argent est un des progrès culturel de
l'époque moderne en particulier les
échanges économiques a été d
personnalisés il n'est plus nécessaire
pour acquérir un bien ou un service d'en
posséder un autre particulier ou bien
d'être quelqu'un de particulier il
suffit de payer le prix de ce point de
vue la monnaie a mis tous les acteurs de
l'e change sur un pied d'égalité
l'argent ancrer plus profondément un
seul niveau de réalité georges sim elle
affirme que l'argent fait disparaître
toutes les différences de nature entre
les objets en les remplaçant par des
différences de degré sur l'échelle de la
valeur des changes ce phénomène entraîne
un nivellement de la réalité tout temps
hier sous le prisme de l'intérêt
économique il tente aussi à favoriser la
réunion des acteurs dans un but
financier
l'argent comme les conflits et associe
efficacement les hommes le problème du
nivellement de toutes les choses par
l'argent c'est qu'il rapproche les
choses les plus nobles et les plus
vulgaires mais il met aussi en évidence
le fait que toute une partie de la
réalité ne peut pas être exprimée en
argent l'amour l'amitié la confiance la
responsabilité les diplômes etc
pour finir si mal fait le même
diagnostic que beaucoup d'autres
penseurs notamment marx
l'argent est devenu une fin il est
d'abord passé de simple moyen à moyens
absolue puis de moyens absolue à fin en
soi
comment l'expliquer simon estime que la
quête de l'argent est une solution
simple pour donner un sens à l'existence
et ce faisant elle détourne l'individu
des questions philosophiques en
définitive l'argent et le nouveau dieu
des hommes et sa dimension quasi divine
se vérifie par le fait que la richesse
confère à partir d'un certain niveau un
pouvoir presque illimitées dans la
société
9e référence l'éthique protestante et
l'esprit du capitalisme max weber
pourquoi cette référence et l
incontournable en sociologie parce
qu'elle permet de comprendre l'influencé
des valeurs et des croyances sur les
conduites humaines en l'occurrence max
bert s'intéresse à l' influence d'un
système de croyances particulier sur la
conduite économique propre au
capitalisme
il est le premier à donner une
explication spécifique de l'histoire du
capitalisme les son explication est
original dans la mesure où elle fait
reposer le développement économique sur
une transformation des mentalités
max weber est d'ailleurs considéré comme
un des fondateurs de la sociologie même
s'il a peu enseignée et qu'il n'a pas
fait école de son vivant bien que
l'éthique protestante et l'esprit du
capitalisme soit un grand classique de
la sociologie son style est plutôt
accessible webber mène des explications
parfois complexes mais il illustre son
propos avec de nombreux exemples et puis
le livre n'est pas énorme il fait moins
de 300 pages donc vous pouvez essayer de
le lit si le sujet vous intéresse
maintenant qu'elle danse ont les idées
essentielles le point de départ de la
sociologie de la religion de webber et
l'idée que pour comprendre les attitudes
des individus et en particulier leurs
comportements économiques il faut
connaître la conception globale de
l'existence qui les anime en tant
qu'acteur
les gens agissent en fonction d'une
certaine vision du monde dont découlent
leurs motivations psychologiques
par exemple on trouve au début de
l'éthique protestante et l'esprit du
capitalisme des analyses statistiques
qui montrent que dans les régions
d'allemagne où coexistent les groupes
religieux les protestants possède un
pourcentage disproportionnée de la
fortune et des positions économiques les
plus importantes cette statistique
suggère l'existence d'un lien entre la
croyance religieuse et la réussite
économique pour vérifier ce lien webber
doit d'abord définir le capitalisme et
l'éthique protestante comme en
définitive le capitalisme à ses yeux
dans les faits il n'existe pas un
capitalisme mais des capitalismes donc
il définit un type idéal du capitalisme
ce qu'il appelle l'esprit du capitalisme
cet esprit se caractérise par la
jonction du désir de profit et de la
discipline à rationnelle qui se
manifeste dans l'organisation du travail
et dans la production ce qui est inédit
dans le capitalisme moderne c'est que le
désir de profits temps à se satisfaire
non par la conquête la spéculation ou l'
aventure mais par la discipline et la
science maintenant comment viber
définit-il à l'éthique protestante saône
analystes se concentre sur la conception
calviniste le grand courant né dans la
deuxième phase de la réforme protestante
l'autre grand courant c'est le
luthéranisme la conception calviniste
combine de manière inédite cinq éléments
idéologiques le caractère insaisissable
de dieu pour les hommes la
prédestination qui signifie que le sort
des hommes à savoir s'ils seront sauvés
ou pas est fixé d'avancé par dieu
la création du monde par dieu pour sa
propre gloire le devoir de l'homme de
travailler à la gloire de dieu et pour
créer son royaume sur cette terre et
enfin le fait que les choses terrestres
relève de l'ordre du péché ça c'est la
définition stricte théorique mais lille
au logis religieuse n'opère pas telle
quelle dans les esprits des croyants
ceux ci interprète la doctrine en
l'occurrence travail à la gloire de dieu
devient dans les faits chercher les
signes de l'élection pour surmonter
l'angoissé liée à l'incertitude du salut
c'est l'interprétation d'une secte
calviniste puis le travail rationnel
régulier constant finit par être
interprétée comme l'obéissance à un
commandement de dieu ainsi l'éthique
protestante a fait du travail et qui
passait dans les tic traditionnels pour
une activité douloureuse le labeur
l'éthique protestante valorise le
travail comme une vocation à la gloire
de dieu pour autant on ne peut pas
résumer les faits de cette croyance par
la formule travailler plus pour gagner
plus max bert établi la conformité
intellectuelle ou spirituelle de
l'éthique protestante et de l'esprit du
capitalisme par la correspondance de
deux de leurs éléments pour le dire en
une phrase l'ascétisme protestants
favorise la logique économique du
capitalisme
en effet comme l'éthique protestante
dévalorise les choses terrestres elle
décourage la consommation du profit et
ce faisant elle encourage l'entrepreneur
à réinvestir le profit or c'est là
précisément le mécanisme économique qui
décuple la production de richesses
d'un côté le capitaliste protestants
travaille dur par vocation pour se
persuader qu'il fait partie des élus de
l'autre il se retient de profiter de la
richesse qu'ils créent parce que sa
religion lui enjoint de satisfaire le
moins possible ses désirs en conclusion
il ne fait que produire produire
produire et il ne consomme jamais
l'éthique protestante exacerbe donc la
volonté de produire des richesses
propres à l'esprit du capitalisme
10e référence traité de sociologie
générale vilfredo pareto
pourquoi cet ouvrage est il
incontournable en sociologie parce qu'il
contient l'analyse de référence sur les
élites c'est à dire l'ensemble des
individus qui sont considérés comme les
meilleurs au sein de la société et je
dis bien un contient parce qu'il ya
d'autres choses dans ce traité de plus
de 1800 pages mais seule la théorie des
élites de pareto est passé à la
postérité
au point qu'il n'existe aucune est dit
monde moderne sérieuse même en anglais
du traité de sociologie générale et par
édition sérieuse je veux dire autre
chose qu'un scan automatique
bourré d'erreurs d'une vieille édition
et comme il n'en existe aucune édition
moderne et sérieuse et bien je ne peux
rien vous dire sur le style de pareto
donc je passe directement au fond alors
en quoi cette référence nous permettent
elles de mieux comprendre la société le
point de départ c'est que la société est
hétérogène il est impossible de la
considérait comme une personne car les
individus qui la composent ont des
valeurs différentes mais pour autant
elle n'est pas un assemblage anarchique
de ce groupe en effet toutes les
sociétés connues comporte la séparation
et en un certain sens l'opposition entre
la masse des individus gouverner et un
petit nombre d'individus qui dominent
l'élite
cette perspective sociologique inscrits
par eto'o dans ce qu'on appelle dans
l'histoire des idées la tradition
machiavélienne machiavel et par eto'o
sont tous les deux italiens petite
remarque l'existence d'élites et
cohérente avec la célèbre loi de pareto
qu'on appelle aussi loi des 80 20 selon
cette loi dans les phénomènes sociaux
une minorité moins de 20% de cause sont
responsables de la majorité plus de 80%
des effets ce qui est confirmé par les
statistiques compilées à partir du début
du 20e siècle or si cette répartition
est systématique alors une minorité
d'individus détiennent toujours à la
majorité des ressources quelle qu'elle
soit ce qui signifie bien qu'il y a
toujours des élites je reviens à la
théorie des élites proprement dit
dans le détail et par eto'o donne deux
définitions de l'élite il yad'abord
l'élite sociale c'est la définition
large qui correspond au petit nombre
d'individus qui sont les meilleurs dans
leurs activités par eto'o donne beaucoup
d'exemples où le succès social de
l'individu peut être notés de 0 à 10 de
ce point de vue même un escroc efficace
ou une prostituée de luxe appartiennent
à l'élite c'est par eto'o qui apporte
cette précision pas moi
seconde définition il ya ensuite l'élite
gouvernante
c'est la définition restreinte élites
gouvernantes qui correspond au petit
nombre d'individus qui parmi ceux qui
ont réussi et exercent des fonctions
politiquement ou socialement dirigeante
et la part étonné pas du tout
complotistes car il précise que cette
élites gouvernantes ne constitue pas un
groupe homogène il y a dans les faits
une concurrence des élites avec des
oppositions des neutralité ou des
alliances de principe ou de circonstance
pourquoi s'intéresser en priorité à
l'élite il y a deux raisons la première
raison c'est que la société est
caractérisée par la nature de ces élites
surtout de ses élites gouvernantes en
particulier la société n'est pas la même
selon que ces élites gouverne le grand
nombre par la force ou par la ruse c'est
une référence de pareto à la métaphore
de machiavel du lion un animal fort et
du renard un animal rusé par exemple les
élites des sociétés démocratiques que
par eto'o appelle plutôt démocratique
pour signaler la dépendance évidente
entre le pouvoir politique et le pouvoir
économique
ces élites préfère gouverné par la ruse
elles maintiennent leur pouvoir par la
propagande en multipliant les
combinaisons politico financières en
revanche les élites des sociétés
traditionnelles où l'activité militaire
était plus importante préféré gouverné
par la force la seconde raison de
s'intéresser à l'élite c'est pour
comprendre le changement social en fait
pour parer tôt la société change quand
sa tête change c'est ce qu'il appelle la
circulation des élites l'histoire
écrit-il dans le traité de sociologie
générale est un cimetière d'aristocratie
l'histoire des sociétés humaines et dit
une autre de ses formules célèbre est en
grande partie l'histoire de la
succession des aristocraties en clair
des minorités privilégiés se forment
lutte à rift au pouvoir en profite et
tente en décadence pour être remplacés
par d'autres minorités pourquoi les
élites tombe-t-elle en décadence soit
elle meurt sur le champ de bataille soit
elles perdent progressivement au bout de
plusieurs générations la force de se
maintenir au pouvoir selon pareto une
élite qui reste trop longtemps au
pouvoir a tendance à essentialiser sa
domination à la croix innés à devenir
trop intellectuel en un mot passive or
la propension à l'action et le
pragmatisme sont cruciaux pour rester au
pouvoir d'un côté les vieilles élites
enrichissent certes la civilisation mais
de l'autre elles deviennent ainsi
incapables de l'action qu'exige l'ordre
social par eto'o trouve que la noblesse
française qui a subi la révolution de
1789 est un bon exemple elle vivait en
parasites dans le pays elle passait son
temps dans des soupes et élégant elle se
passionnait pour la philosophie et
voulait délivrer le monde de la
superstition sans se douter qu'elle met
mal et être écrasé une élite ne
peut-elle pas se maintenir au pouvoir
comme il n'y a pas d'harmonie durable
entre les compétences et les positions
sociales il y a toujours d'une part des
individus qui méritent de déchoir de
l'élite et d'autre part des individus
qui méritent de l'intégrer pour
préserver sa domination et par là la
stabilité sociale l'élite en place peut
recourir à deux stratégies ou bien
éliminer les candidats à l'élite par
exemple par l'exil ou la mise à mort ou
bien les absorber ce qui est
particulièrement efficace pour empêcher
les révolutions paraît tôt trouve que
l'élite anglaise le fait très bien
11e référence essai sur le don marcel
mauss
pourquoi cette référence mérite t elle
d'être dans cette liste parce que c'est
la plus célèbre contestation de la thèse
selon laquelle la société fonctionne
comme un marché en réalité les changes
entre les hommes n'est pas forcément
économique david graiver l'anthropologue
américain qui s'est fait connaître dans
les années 2010 avec son livre culte sur
la dette et sa théorie sur les boules
chez job les jobs à la conte en français
david graiver dit de laisser sur le don
que sais je cite la plus magnifique
réfutation jamais écrite des hypothèses
qui sont à la base de la théorie
économique
ce livre a rendu célèbres marcel mauss
qui était le disciple mais aussi le
neveu
mille dürckheim dürckheim qui comme je
voulais dit à propos de son livre sur le
suicide est un des fondateurs de la
sociologie après moss lui même n'est pas
considéré comme un sociologue mais comme
un anthropologue néanmoins les choses
intellectuels des deux disciplines se
recoupent beaucoup et laissé sur le don
a été très influent dans la réflexion
sociologique et plus généralement dans
la pensée sur la forme ce livre est
difficile d'accès vous aurez
probablement du mal à le terminer si
vous n'êtes pas un universitaire ou un
étudiant avancé et honnêtement l'intérêt
de vous infliger cette souffrance est
limité si vous n'êtes pas à l'université
maintenant quelles sont les idées
importantes de laisser sur le don en
analysant les cérémonies décrite par des
études technologiques marcel mauss met
en lumière le fait que les changes sert
surtout à régler quantité d'interactions
sociales nécessaires à la vie et à la
cohésion de la communauté dans les
sociétés archaïques et étudier le don
est une pratique courante entre
collectivités et non pas entre individus
ainsi les clans et les tribus échange
des biens matériels mais également des
festins des femmes des politesses des
traditions et ses mots se met en
évidence trois obligations qui donne sa
force au rituel du don données rendre et
recevoir ces actes sont d'une part
obligatoire sous peine d'exclusion de la
collectivité mais d'autre part ils sont
également effectué volontairement car il
recèle un enjeu de prestige social le
don peut donc ne pas être gratuit et
être une manière de rabaisser l'autre ou
de le mettre en situation de dette il ne
se réduit cependant pas à cela moss
évoque aussi une autre forme de
cérémonie des changes la cula observé en
mélanésie qu'a eue elle à la cula et l
dépourvu de rivalités de combat et de
destructions la conclusion qui découle
de l'analyse des sociétés archaïques et
que le don à une vertu sociale il est un
rituel social ayant des répercussions
sur la collectivité tout entière toutes
sortes d'institutions juridique
religieuse morale c ce prime à travers
le don sous des formes spécifiques de
prestations et de distribution tout va
et vient et crimes hausse comme s'il y
avait un échange constant d'une matière
spirituel comprenant choses et hommes
entre les clans et les individus
répartis entre les rangs les sexes et
les générations la dimension quasi
magique du rituel du don s'explique par
le fait que l'objet données garde
quelque chose du donateur ce qui oblige
le donataire en quoi cette théorie
permettait de comprendre le monde
moderne pour moss la logique du don
survie dans les sociétés contemporaines
bien que ces sociétés fonctionnent comme
des marchés les relations sociales qui
suivent encore des rituels de dons et de
contre dont par exemple dans les règles
de la politesse dans les obligations
d'offrir des cadeaux dans le refus par
honneur de la charité ou encore dans la
solidarité sociale marcel mauss en
conclut que le don constitue une morale
universelle et éternelle qui contribue à
la cohésion des communautés il en déduit
que les systèmes sociaux des sociétés
marchandes ne doivent pas dissimuler la
violence sous une apparence de
générosité sans calcul sinon le don
perdra sa vertu cohésive
deuxième référence sur le processus de
civilisation
norbert elias jeu là vous je n'ai pas
pensé moi même à ce livre mais j'ai
trouvé qu'en 1998 l'association
internationale de sociologie à classer
sur le processus de civilisation
septième sur la liste des livres de
sociologie les plus importants du 20e
siècle
pourtant ce livre ne s'est pas imposé
tout de suite comme une référence à sa
publication en 1939 personne ne s'y
intéresse parce que norbert elias est
juif son travail sort finalement de
l'oubli trente ans plus tard grâce à une
réédition allemande puis l'édition de
poche française devient même un best
seller dans les années 1970 en france
nous ne connaissons pas le titre de ce
livre ne le cherchez pas sur amazon nous
ne le connaissons pas parce qu'il est
paru en français en deux volumes qui
s'intitule la civilisation des moeurs et
la dynamique de l'occident
pourquoi sur le processus de
civilisation est il si important en
sociologie
parce qu'il est temps et permet de mieux
comprendre le concept de civilisation
pour le dire en une phrase la
civilisation ce ne sont pas seulement
les conquêtes de l'esprit humain se sont
aussi d'autres choses que les penseurs
antérieure à elias avait négligé pour
oublier la thèse plus précise du livre
c'est que l'apparition de la
civilisation occidentale s explique par
la conjonction de deux phénomènes
indissociables premier phénomène les
individus suivent des règles morales de
plus en plus contraignantes et second
phénomène l'état qui détient le pouvoir
est de plus en plus centralisée le
premier phénomène est analysée dans le
premier volume la civilisation des
moeurs et le second phénomène dans le
second volume
la dynamique de l'occident sur la forme
sur le processus de civilisation ne
plaira probablement pas un amateur déjà
il y en a avec les deux volumes pour
plus de 800 pages donc la lecture
représente un sacré investissement de
temps ensuite la réflexion est fine et
parfois noyé par les récits historiques
détaillées ce qui découragera les gens
qui aiment aller à l'essentiel il ya
bien des passages intéressants mais il
ya aussi des répétitions qui sont
fatigantes quoi retenir sur le fond
maintenant je commence par le premier
volume la civilisation des moeurs avec
une démarche d'historien norbert elias
analyse concrètement les moeurs de la
civilisation occidentale et leur
transformation de la fin du moyen-âge à
l'époque contemporaine il s'intéresse à
différentes choses par exemple ou règles
de savoir vivre aux proverbes ou encore
à l'émergence de la pudeur liés à la
sexualité
l'idée essentielle qu'il tire de son
analyse c'est que la discipline du corps
social est passé par la discipline du
corps individuel concrètement à partir
grosso modo de la renaissance les
européens se sont mises à dévaloriser et
donc à dissimuler les fonctions
naturelles par exemple ils ne font plus
leur besoin en public sans gêne il
utilise découvert à table ils sont plus
propres il parle moins ouvertement de
sexe un exemple amusant c'est le crachat
d'après elias les occidentaux ont
longtemps considéré que crash était un
besoin sur elle mais la dévalorisation
des fonctions naturelles a provoqué
l'interdiction du crachat et
l'interdiction et même parfois légal
j'ai découvert à mes dépens il ya une
dizaine d'années dans une rue de moscou
il reste une question quelle est
l'origine de cette évolution elle vient
de l'aristocratie qui a voulu se
distinguer dans le comportement
individuel de la bourgeoisie ensuite ces
nouvelles normes aristocratique se sont
progressivement diffusés à toute la
société puis les individus les ont
intériorisé c'est à dire qu'ils se sont
mis à les suivre sans y penser
la diffusion et l'intériorisation de ces
règles c'est le processus de
civilisation
je passe maintenant au second volume la
dynamique de l'occident l'idée
essentielle en est que la clé du
développement politique de la
civilisation occidentale et la formation
d'un pouvoir étatique et centralisées
dans les faits les grandes monarchies
roux progressivement désarmer les
seigneurs féodaux en obtenant le
monopole de la violence légitime avec le
contrôle de l'armée et de la justice
elias met en évidence ce processus en
reconstituant la construction de l'état
absolutiste en france mais quel est le
rapport entre la centralisation du
pouvoir et le processus de civilisation
et bien la domination monopolistique de
l'état a permis d'apaiser la rivalité
entre les différents groupes sociaux
tout du moins elles empêchent cette
rivalité de dégénérer d'être trop
violente ce faisant le monopole étatique
à pacifier les relations sociales c'est
cela aussi le processus de civilisation
en conclusion elias montre que la même
évolution s'est produite à deux échelles
celle de l'individu et celle de la
société l'individu occidentale c'est
civilisé en apprenant à se maîtriser lui
même c'est ce que montre le premier
volume la société occidentale hes et
civilisé en apprenant à se maîtriser
elle même c'est ce que montre le second
volume
13e référence cahiers de prison antonio
gramsci
pourquoi cette référence est elle
importante
parce que c'est le livre qui a
popularisé l'idée selon laquelle dans la
société le pouvoir est fondamentalement
idéologique en d'autres termes le groupe
social qui domine est celui dont le
système d'idées et de valeurs domine
marx avait déjà expliqué cela mais
antonio gramsci un marxiste italien de
la première moitié du 20e siècle
il explique encore mieux ils appellent
cela l'hégémonie culturelle je vous en
dit plus dans quelques instants
comme le titre l'indiqué le livre n'a
pas été écrit à une terrasse de café en
1926 le régime de mussolini emprisonne g
ci parce qu'il est un dirigeant est un
intellectuel communiste le procureur
fascistes ne fait pas mystère de ses
intentions il dit texto pour 20 ans nous
devons empêcher ce cerveau de
fonctionner quand on a rien d'autre de
mieux à faire qu écrire et bien on écrit
de 1929 à 1935 g ci remplit des carnets
de notes une trentaine au total de ses
analyses sur un large éventail de sujets
notamment l'histoire et le nationalisme
italien la révolution française le
fascisme le fordisme la société civile
le folklore la religion et la haute
culture et la culture populaire sur la
forme les cahiers de prison manque
forcément un peu de cohérence gramsci
n'expose pas sa pensée de manière
systématique il évoque beaucoup de
sujets et passent facilement de l'un à
l'autre mais c'est dû aux conditions
dans lesquelles ils écrit après son
style est bien plus agréable que celui
d'un sociologue de métier gramsci avait
d'ailleurs été un journaliste prolifique
et sa plume était réputé contrairement à
la plupart des auteurs de cette liste il
n'était pas un universitaire mais un
homme d'action sur le fond ce qui est
important pour votre culture générale
c'est comme je vous l'aï dit au début
l'idée d'hégémonie culturelle
gramsci explique que le groupe social
dominant a acquis sa domination en
propageant ses croyances et ses
pratiques dans la société tout entière
dans le détail la diffusion de la
culture dominante passe par plusieurs
canaux à l'époque de la rédaction des
cahiers de prison l'école
église les partis politiques les
institutions scientifiques
universitaires ou artistique les médias
de masse et même les organisations de
travailleurs sont des foyers culturels
dont le pouvoir bourgeois se sert pour
maintenir son hégémonie et produire la
culture diffusées par ces foyers c'est
la fonction des intellectuels par
exemple les intellectuels bourgeois
préserve l'hégémonie culturelle de leur
classe en faisant céder les travailleurs
aux sirènes du nationalisme du
consumérisme et plus généralement de
l'individualisme bourgeon gramsci
affirme plus généralement que chaque
classe sociale sécrète son propre groupe
d'intellectuels organiques en ayant ses
propres intellectuelle une classe
sociale peut prendre conscience de son
identité parce que les discours de ses
propres intellectuels vont légitimer ses
attentes et ses revendications formulées
un projet historique ou des perspectives
d'avenir de ce diagnostic gramsci tire
une nouvelle version de la révolution
communiste une confrontation frontale
avec les institutions dominantes et
probablement vouée à l'échec par
conséquent la conquête du pouvoir doit
plutôt passer par une lente préparation
des esprits dans la société gramsci
invite donc la classe ouvrière à
subvertir progressivement les esprits à
diffuser et grâce à ses propres
intellectuelle ces valeurs dans le
domaine public afin d'installer son
hégémonie culturelle c'est ce qu'il
appelle la révolution passive avec cette
théorie gramsci est devenu le meilleur
penseur marxiste du 20e siècle et le
penseur italien le plus étudié à
l'étranger avec machiavel qu'il a
beaucoup lu d'ailleurs et dont il parle
dans ses cahiers de prison et il y a une
chose qui est remarquable c'est que
gramsci a réussi à entrer dans
l'histoire de la pensée dans des
conditions très défavorables isolée du
monde extérieur en mauvaise santé coupé
de ses camarades et surtout sans aucun
espoir à l'époque de voir ses écrits
publiés
14e référence les origines du
totalitarisme
hannah arendt ce livre est important
parce que c'est l'analyse de référence
totalitarisme définit comme le système
politique qui impose à la société dans
son ensemble ainsi qu aux individus qui
la composent la toute puissance d'un
état et d'une idéologie et deux
meilleurs exemples historiques sont
l'allemagne nazie et l'urss stalinienne
hannah arendt n'était pas sociologue et
elle a même critiqué la discipline
intellectuelle qui est la sociologie
mais pour autant les origines du
totalitarisme mérite sa place dans cette
liste parce que le totalitarisme y est
étudiée non pas simplement comme un
régime politique mais comme un phénomène
social ce livre est une trilogie dont
chaque tome fait 300 400 pages le
premier volet s'intitule sur
l'antisémitisme
le deuxième volet l'impérialisme et
enfin le troisième volet celui qui a eu
le plus d'influencé dans la pensée
sociologique le système totalitaire
sur la forme le style est plutôt
accessible s'il n'est pas étonnant étant
donné que hannah arendt a été
journaliste avant d'être universitaire
en revanche la lecture est quand même
fastidieuse tente il ya de détails
quelles sont les idées essentielles le
point de départ de hannah arendt ne
plaît pas à tout le monde elle pose que
les similitudes entre fascisme et
communisme sont plus importantes que
leurs différences par conséquent les
deux peuvent être rangés dans une
catégorie unique le totalitarisme pour
l'analyser elle s'intéresse
essentiellement à l'allemagne nazie et à
l'urss stalinienne
comment caractériser le totalitarisme
d'un point de vue sociologique c'est un
phénomène de masse hannah arendt définit
les masses comme des groupes des
structures et amorphe et en cela prêt à
toutes les transformations et à toutes
les aventures c'est le capitalisme qui a
rendu possible la transformation du
peuple en masse en détruisant les
solidarités traditionnelles
sur le plan psychologique les masses
n'ont pas de croyance forte et elle sont
confuses d'où leur grande capacité à
accepter l'idéologie et à la mettre en
pratique autre caractéristique le
totalitarisme assure la prédominance
d'un parti qui a une idéologie et une
structure sectaire c'est parti véhicule
un discours fataliste qui ressemble par
certains traits au mythe des sociétés
primitives et dans sa structure et son
fonctionnement ils forment une
communauté organisée spécifiquement par
degré d'initiation comme dans les
sociétés secrètes le chef il possède un
statut particulier sa responsabilité est
totale son groupe est soudé autour de
lui et complice de son entreprise
dernière caractéristique enfin le
totalitarisme plonge la société dont ce
que hannah arendt appelle la désolation
ce concept signifie que la terreur
l'emprise idéologique et la prévalence
des masses isole l'individu d'une
manière inédite qui l'empêchent de
penser la réalité il perd évidemment sa
liberté extérieur puisqu'il ne peut plus
déterminer librement les buts de son
action mais il perd aussi sa liberté
intérieure dans la mesure où la
brutalité et l'omniprésence de
l'idéologie totalitaire
paralyse la réflexion individuelle
hannah arendt donne une conclusion
philosophique même métaphysique à son
analyse sociologique en privant l'homme
de ses libertés extérieure et intérieure
le totalitarisme déshumanise l'homme il
le rabaisse jusqu'à lui faire perdre sa
dignité d'homme
15e référence la mise en scène de la vie
quotidienne erving goffman cet ouvrage
est une référence en sociologie pour
deux raisons en premier lieu c'est un
des livres les plus importants de la
branche de la sociologie qu'on appelle
la micro sociologie qui étudie les
phénomènes sociaux à l'échelle des
petits groupes comme la famille le
couple les pères etc ce livre est un
classique dans les facultés en second
lieu son prisme d'analysé originales
erving goffman compare en effet les
interactions humaines à une pièce de
théâtre ce qu'il appelle le modèle
dramaturgique de la vie sociale c'est
certes une perspective originale en
sociologie mais l'idée n'est pas neuve
les grecs et les romains disaient déjà
que le monde est un théâtre et puis vous
connaissez peut-être la tirade de
shakespeare le monde entier est un
théâtre et tous hommes et femmes n'en
sont que les acteurs et notre vie durant
nous joue plusieurs rôles c'est tiré de
la pièce comme il vous plaira voilà pour
les deux raisons de compter la mise en
scène de la vie quotidienne parmi les
références incontournables en sociologie
en outre il est aussi dans le classement
des livres les plus importants du xxème
siècle de l'association internationale
de sociologie
en france l ouvrage est divisée en deux
tomes la présentation de soi et les
relations en public qui sont tous les
deux disponibles sur amazon il y en a
pour plus de 600 pages mais ça se lit
plutôt bien erving goffman fourni
beaucoup d'exemples et d'anecdotes qui
rendent le propos plus concret et donc
plus accessible je passe au fond du
livre comment la métaphore du théâtre
nous permettait de comprendre la vie
sociale comme l'a dit shakespeare nous
sommes des acteurs qui jouent une
variété de rôles
le public ce sont les autres individus
qui nous observe et qui réagissent à nos
représentations c'est à dire à ce que
nous donnons à voir de nous mêmes le
cadre ce sont le décor les accessoires
et le lieu où se déroule l'interaction
sociale
l'idée essentielle à tirer de la
métaphore c'est que quel que soit le
contexte social les individus gère en
permanence l'image qu'il donne de même
chacun essaie de se présenter et de se
comporter de manière à éviter de se
mettre dans l'embarras ou de mettre les
autres dans l'embarras et pour atteindre
cet objectif les individus font en sorte
de définir la situation dans laquelle
ils sont placés de la même manière c'est
à dire qu'ils comprennent ce qui est
censé se passer dans cette situation ce
qu'ils doivent attendre les uns des
autres et par conséquent comment se
comporter dans cette situation
dans le détail erving goffman distingue
trois types de situation sociale
quotidienne
tout d'abord les situations où
l'individu acteur joue devant le public
son comportement est forcément influencé
par les attentes du public il y a un
rôle à tenir ensuite les situations où
il est en coulisses la libérer du regard
du public il peut se détendre et être
lui même il abandonne son rôle et enfin
les situations où il interagit avec le
public en dehors de la scène il peut
avoir un rôle différent à jouer en
fonction des personnes qu'ils
rencontrent
kaufmann donne également une portée
sociologique à des termes de l'univers
théâtral ce qu'il appelle la performance
de l'individu en tant qu'acteur est
important pour le groupe car cela comme
unique consciemment ou inconsciemment
des informations sur la situation ainsi
que sur le rôle de l'acteur ce qu'il
appelle l'apparence ce sont les éléments
de la performance qui signale au public
le statut social de l'individu acteur ce
qu'il appelle la manière c'est la
manière dont l'individu joue le rôle il
faut bien sûr que la manière soit
cohérente avec l'apparence sinon le
public sera perdue et enfin ce qu'il
appelle la façade c'est la partie de la
performance qui sert à définir la
situation pour le public à propos de
cette idée et goffman file la métaphore
du théâtre en expliquant que la société
impose à l'individu certains scénarios
de comportement dans certaines
situations
après cette énumération je suis assez
d'accord avec les critiques du livre qui
disent que son analyse certes original
en sociologie et surtout descriptive
qu'elle ne fait pas beaucoup voire pas
du tout avancer notre compréhension du
monde
16e référence la construction sociale de
la réalité peter berg heures et tomasz
luckman il paraît que c'est un des
ouvrages de sociologie les plus sur lui
il passe même dans certaines facultés
pour le livre de sociologie par
excellence il a popularisé à la fin des
années 1960 un courants sociologiques le
constructivisme dont la thèse
fondamentale est dans le titre du livre
la réalité c'est à dire ce qui existe
pour les hommes la réalité de la vie
humaine n'est pas objective elle n'est
pas réel au même titre qu'une pierre ou
un morceau de bois la réalité de la vie
humaine est construite par la société
seulement on ne s'en rend pas compte car
les constructions sociales qui dure et
qui sont transmises de génération en
génération deviennent des institutions
au point que leur existence nous
paraître évidente et objectivement
l comme je l' ai déjà dit à propos du
livre d'auguste compte cette idée n'est
pas neuve les sophistes de la grèce
antique entre autres avaient déjà
compris que le monde des hommes
fonctionne sur des conventions nous
partageons des croyances qui deviennent
avec le temps des institutions puis des
évidences qui ont valeur de réalité au
même titre qu'une pierre ou un morceau
de bois dans nos esprits si la
construction sociale de la réalité n'est
pas un énorme pavé fait environ 350
pages il est quand même difficile
d'accès il ne s'adresse pas à l'amateur
d'idées mais à l'étudiant de sociologie
ou au futur sociologue professionnels le
propos est particulièrement abstrait
l'érudition déployés qui mélange un
grand nombre de traditions
intellectuelles compliquer les choses et
enfin le style de peter berg et tomasz
leukemans et lourd quoi retenir du fonds
maintenant la première idée importante
et que l'individu vit sa réalité
quotidienne à travers des schémas de
pensée adapté à la réalité sociale ou
tipi fication dans le jargon des auteurs
ces schémas de pensée lui permettre
notamment d'anticiper les comportements
des autres individus qu'ils rencontrent
en face à face et de s'y adapter
ses schémas sont transmissibles par le
langage qui ordonne en cela la réalité
quotidienne enfin il révèle le rapport
profond de l'individu au monde quotidien
l'individu part du principe que ce monde
est réel qu'il comprend ce qui s'y passe
et qu il le partage avec d'autres
individus dont c'est aussi le monde
quotidien
la deuxième idée importante et
l'institutionnalisation de la réalité
sociale pour comprendre la naissance
d'une institution il faut partir de
l'idée de répétition une action répété
par un individu devient une habitude une
habitude observé par un autre individu
devient ce que les auteurs nomment une
type ification et enfin une type
ification pertinente pour plusieurs
individus devient une type ification dit
réciproque soit une institution qu'on
peut définir plus simplement comme une
structure durable qui contribuent à
l'organisation de la société cette
définition n'est pas dans le livre est
les deux mois en conclusion c'est la
routinisation de l'action humaine qui
aboutit aux institutions c'est à dire
que c'est elle et qui est au point de
départ de la construction de la réalité
sociale enfin troisième idée importante
ce que les auteurs appellent les
socialisation primaire et secondaire la
socialisation primaire c'est le
processus d'adaptation de l'enfant à la
vie en société cela consiste pour lui
dire simplement à généraliser les
attentes de ses proches par exemple si
sa mère considère que tel comportement
est approprié dans telle situation
l'enfant va en déduire que c'est le
comportement approprié pour l'ensemble
de la société
quant à la socialisation dit secondaire
c'est le processus d'adaptation de
l'individu qui n'est plus un enfant à la
vie sociale notamment la vie sociale du
monde académique et ensuite la vie
sociale du monde professionnel mais quel
est le rapport entre l'idée de la
socialisation et l'idée de la
construction sociale de la réalité
le rapport c'est que comme la réalité
sociale est une construction l'individu
ne la saisit pas instantanément comme il
saisit la réalité d'une pierre par les
sens il a donc besoin d'intégrer au
contact des autres individus tout ce que
comporte la réalité sociale
la comparaison qui me vient à l'esprit
c'est l'installation et la mise à jour
d'un logiciel
17e référence la société de consommation
jean baudrillard ce livre est important
parce qu'il est l'analyse de référence
de la société de consommation il dit
c'est que notre nouveau mode de vie ce
qu'on appelle le consumérisme tout au
long de notre histoire nous avons vécu
dans la rareté notre mot d'ordre était
la frugalité ne pas gaspiller la
nourriture éviter la dépense faire des
économies mais notre mentalité a changé
dans les deux derniers siècles nous
sommes désormais consumériste ce qui
signifie que nous valorisons la
consommation c'est à dire le fait de
nous servir de biens et de services nous
valorisons cela parce que nous sommes
persuadés que plus nous consommons de
biens et de services plus nous serons
heureux
le livre la société de consommation et
donc une référence essentielle pour
comprendre notre société actuelle jean
baudrillard y explique comment
l'abondance à transformer notre rapport
à nous mêmes aux autres et au monde nous
sommes les hommes les plus riches de
l'histoire mais nous ne sommes pas les
plus heureux et il y à plus grave nous
ne savons plus où nous allons écrire en
1970 la société de consommation est
rapidement devenu une référence il faut
dire que son titre est vendeur et plus
particulièrement une référence de la
contre culture c'est-à-dire de la
culture qui contestent la culture
dominante baudrillard était une figure
intellectuelle de mai 68 pour l'anecdote
si vous preniez le métro parisien en
2007 vous avez peut-être vu des affiches
avec un homme torse nu tenant un livre
ouvert et bien ce livre c'est la société
de consommation c'était une pub des
galeries lafayette avec l'écrivain
frédéric beigbeder et c'était bien sûr
un clin d'oeil pour les initiés seules
les personnes qui connaissent l ouvrage
en question pouvaient comprendre que le
publicitaire leur disait que la critique
de la société de consommation est
récupéré par la société de consommation
soit plus généralement la contre-culture
par la culture dominante que dire de ce
livre sur la forme il n'est pas très
long un peu plus de 300 pages le propos
est bien subdivisée en partie sous
parties et paragraphe mais c'est quand
même difficile à comprendre pour
l'honnête homme comme beaucoup
d'intellectuels de son époque
baudrillard abusent des termes
techniques et il opte trop souvent pour
des constructions de phrases complexes
mais bon j'ai réussi à le lire
maintenant qu'est ce qui est essentiel
sur le fond l'analyse de la société de
consommation poursuit celle développée
dans le système des objets le premier
ouvrage de baudrillard elle part de
l'idée selon laquelle l'utilité d'un
objet ne se résume pas à remplir une
fonction ni et pour nous consommateurs à
satisfaire un besoin objectif comme nous
le fait comprendre la publicité une
machine à laver est plus qu'une machine
à laver pour baudrillard c'est la
logique du désir humain et non pas les
lois de l'économie qui dit la vérité sur
la société de consommation
ils expliquent plus précisément le
mécanisme de la consommation en réalité
les consommateurs n'achètent pas des
biens et des services ils échangent des
signes qui manifestent leur statut
social et les publicitaires ont compris
cela il manipule les consommateurs en
les invitant à enrichir à
narcissiquement leur identité par
l'affiliation à des modèles artificiel
par exemple ils nous donnent envie
d'acheter du café en implantant dans
notre esprit la croyance que telles
stars prestigieuses consomme ce qu'a
fait le problème c'est que ce mécanisme
est devenu le mode de fonctionnement de
la société toutes les dimensions de
l'existence y compris la culture et même
les relations humaines fonctionne
désormais sur le mode de les change de
signe or baudrillard pense que cette
évolution détruit les bases
psychologique de l'être humain il ya
encore d'autres idées intéressantes dans
la société de consommation mais c'est
cette idée la logique psychologique de
la consommation qui est la plus
importante
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur cette
référence à les lire mon résumé détaillé
sur mille idées de culture générale le
lien est dans la description
18e référence surveiller et punir michel
foucault ce livre est important parce
que c'est l'analyse de référence de ce
qu'est le pouvoir dans les sociétés
modernes
michel foucault il dissèque le pouvoir
sous un angle nouveau celui de la
discipline c'est à dire les règles de
conduite dictée par l'autorité cet angle
d'analysé est caractéristique de ce
qu'on appelle la déconstruction le
mouvement intellectuel dont le projet
est de révéler que la manière dont la
société fonctionne ses valeurs ses
institutions et c'est que tout cela est
une construction et qu'il est donc
possible de déconstruire le
fonctionnement de la société pour
ensuite la reconstruire les universités
américaines se sont intéressés à ce
mouvement dans les années 1980 et l'ont
baptisé la french filles sur la forme
surveiller et punir n'est pas ce qu'il
ya de pire
mais il faut quand même s'accrocher je
les rues il ya un an il y à du jargon
les phrases pourraient être construites
plus simplement et le propos s'enlise
souvent dans l'analyse de documents
d'archivés qui ne sont pas passionnant
pour l'honnête homme mais bon ça vaut le
coup de faire l'effort parce que ce que
dit
coucou est vraiment intéressant pour
comprendre ce qu'est réellement le
pouvoir dans la société moderne quelles
sont les idées essentielles du livre
michel foucault commence par évoquer la
disparition des supplices depuis la fin
du xviiie siècle en europe l'évolution
est double la punition n'est plus un
spectacle comme dans les châtiments
public et en même temps elle touche de
moins en moins au corps cela révèle une
transformation de la nature du pouvoir
qui ne souhaite plus manifester ses
excès c'est dans le chapitre 1 de
surveiller et punir que foucault donne
sa fameuse définition du pouvoir à
partir du concept de micro pouvoir le
nouveau système punitif présuppose une
nouvelle conception du pouvoir
ce n'est plus un privilège mais un
réseau de relations où s'exerce
d'innombrables rapports de force ayant
pour fonction de normaliser les
comportements les micros pouvoir sont
exercées par certains individus les
parents les professeurs les médecins etc
sur d'autre part certaines institutions
les asiles les prisons etc voire par
certains discours pour le dire
simplement le pouvoir s'exerce désormais
surtout par le conditionnement par
exemple les prisons modernes
fonctionnent moins par la contrainte
directe mais en culpabilisant les
consciences d'individuels le pouvoir
disparaît derrière une architecture qui
contraint les captifs de manière
indirecte sans avoir à user de violence
mais en s'appuyant sur la connaissance
des individus a conditionné c'est la
concrétisation du panoptique le concept
de prison circulaire du philosophe
jeremy bentham ou un surveillant situé
dans une tour centrale peut observer
sans jamais être vus dans ce concept
l'enfermement agit davantage sur l'âme
que sur le corps de l'homme il le
conditionne enfin l'évolution du système
carcéral reflète le développement du
contrôle des individus dans la société
dans son ensemble
le modèle du panoptique inspire aux
institutions de pouvoir la volonté de
surveiller le plus grand nombre comme le
surveillant observe les prisonniers
depuis sa tour centrale ainsi les
dispositifs disciplinaire se multiplient
dans la société les écoles les
pensionnats où les casernes par exemple
contrôler désormais leurs éléments en
main sur le conditionnement par la
discipline cette nouvelle forme de
pouvoir fait de l'individu son propre
censeurs comme je voulais dit j'ai lu ce
livre deux fois même mais je n'ai pas
encore trouvé le temps de le résumer si
vous regardez cette vidéo plusieurs mois
ou plusieurs années après sa publication
regardez dans la description ou
directement sur le site et peut-être que
vous trouverez mon résumé détaillé de
surveiller et punir
19e référence la distinction pierre
bourdieu cette référence est importante
parce qu'elle montre le poids de la
société dans l'élaboration des
préférences individuelles le sens commun
a dit que nos goûts sont un don de la
nature que ce sont des préférences
authentiquement liés à notre
personnalité il dit aussi que je cite
les goûts et les couleurs ça ne se
discute pas mais l'observation
sociologiques montrent que nos goûts
sont en réalité liée à notre position
dans la société la distinction qui
présente la théorie des goûts c'est des
styles de vie de bourdieu ce livret est
considéré comme un des ouvrages de
sociologie les plus importants du 20e
siècle comme la plupart des bouquins de
bourdieu celui ci est très difficile à
lire il ya beaucoup de vocabulaire
technique le style est dépourvu
d'élégance littéraire les constructions
de phrases sont compliquées certains
disent que c'est pour imiter proust et
pour ne rien arranger bourdieu s'amuse à
faire des jeux de mots qui perdent un
peu plus le lecteur enfin le propos
s'appuie sur un énorme et minutieux
travail d'enquêté dont les détails ne
sont pas toujours passionnant maintenant
quelles sont les idées essentielles de l
ouvrage la thèse est que les pratiques
culturelles sont le fruit d'une logique
sociale elles s'inscrivent dans une
hiérarchie où elles sont classées en
fonction de leur légitimité ainsi
certains domaines culturels sont
considérés comme noble notamment les
arts classiques tandis que d'autres le
sont beaucoup moins
le cinéma la chanson populaire à la
bande dessinée etc le choix des domaines
auxquels les individus s'intéresse
rentrer dès lors dans des stratégies
leur permettant de s'intégrer à une
classe en se distinguant d'autres
classes ils ont de nombreuses
opportunités de 2 la preuve de
l'appartenance à un groupe social les
choix vestimentaires la décoration
intérieure les loisirs les voyages etc
dans le détail les classes dominantes
acquièrent leur compétence culturelle
grâce à la famille et à l'institution
scolaire elle accumule se faisant à côté
de leur capitale économique un capital
culturel qui constitue un fort enjeu
symbolique mais bon dieu précise que les
deux types de capital ne vont pas
forcément de pair le capital de certains
agents sociaux et surtout économique les
cadres d'entreprises par exemple quand
celui d'autres agents et principalement
culturel les professeurs par exemple une
autre idée essentielle du livre est ce
que bourdieu appelle l'habitus il
élabore ce concept pour exprimer
l'ensemble des dispositions intériorisée
par un individu lors de sa socialisation
au sein d'un couple
les conditions d'existence propre au
groupe font naître des principes
inconscient de perception de pensée et
d'action partagé par tous les membres
c'est pour ça que les membres se
caractérise par les mêmes pratiques et
jugements culturel les dimensions les
plus fermes de l'habitus sont acquises
durant l'enfance au sein de la famille
elle donne naissance à de véritables
style de vie fondée sur la distinction
mais le style de vie née de l'habitus
est plus large que les seuls pratiques
culturelles car il désigne l'ensemble
des goûts des croyances et des pratiques
d'un groupe après l'habitude ce n'est
pas fixe il peut évoluer en fonction des
choix de l'agent et des influences qui
s'exercent sur lui on retrouve donc
quand même dans ce concept le mélange de
déterminisme et de liberté qui habite
l'individu
bourdieu analyse également les faits de
la logique sociale d'égout sur les
classes dominées par exemple la petite
bourgeoisie se caractérise par sa
déférence face à la culture parce
qu'elle a un profond respect de l'ordre
établi et un fort désir d'ascension
sociale ainsi les individus de la petite
bourgeoisie font preuve de ce que
bourdieu appelle une bonne volonté
culturelle en imitant les pratiques et
les jugements des classes supérieures
les classes populaires quant à elles se
définissent par leur acceptation de la
domination culturelle elle se condamne
dès lors pour mon dieu à les goûts
simples et modestes guidés par le
nécessaire et par rapport à ses goûts la
sophistication culturelle passe pour une
forme de reniement de virilité
20e référence la révolte des élites
christopher lasch cette référence est
importante parce que c'est probablement
la meilleure explication du malaise des
démocraties contemporaines les citoyens
qui y ont le sentiment que quelque chose
ne tourner pas rond ce livre nous
explique pourquoi son analyse porte sur
la démocratie américaine mais elle vaut
pour toutes les démocraties occidentales
en france notamment elle nourrit les
réflexions sur la crise du vivre
ensemble depuis les années 2000
l'expression révolte des élites renvoie
au livre la révolte des masses qui date
de 1929 du philosophe espagnol josé
ortega y gasset alors que cet auteur
considéré lui à l'époque que les masses
incultes menacer l'ordre social et les
traditions civilisatrice de la culture
occidentale christopher lasch affirme
près de soixante dix ans plus tard dans
la révolte 2 et vite que ce sont
désormais les élites qui menacent la
démocratie et plus généralement
l'épanouissement de l'occident en tant
que civilisation comme d'autres auteurs
de ma liste christopher lasch n'est pas
sociologue de formation il était prof
d'histoire à l'université aux états unis
c'est en constatant les mutations de la
société de son époque ce qu'on appelle à
la révolution des moeurs qu'il s'est
décidé à décrire le présent plutôt qu'à
travailler sur des archives
c'est certainement grâce à sa formation
d'historien professionnel qu'il
développe son propos avec rigueur et
sans chercher la polémique ce qui n'est
pas évident lorsqu'on écrit sur les
élites en même temps la révolte des
élites est un livre facile d'accès on
peut dire que le style et démocratique
dans la mesure où il permet à tout le
monde de comprendre les idées de
l'auteur la seule limite c'est qu'un
lecteur qui ne connaît pas un minimum
l'histoire des états unis aura du mal à
suivre certains développements
maintenant qu'est ce qui est essentiel
dans le livre l'idée centrale vous
l'avait saisie c'est qu'il y à une
coupure de plus en plus profonde entre
le peuple et les élites la coupure est
déjà matériel l'implication des élites
dans les grandes villes les grandes
entreprises
la sectorisation de l'économie et la
mondialisation place les élites à part
des citoyens ordinaires mais la coupure
est aussi intellectuel car les élites
promeuvent des idéologies politiques en
complet décalage avec les préoccupations
du peuple et moralement enfin elle
méprise ceux qui n'appartiennent pas à
leur caste par exemple les américains
aisé et cultivé de la côte est méprise
ceux des états du centre
la coupure entraîne le déclin du
discours démocratique christopher lasch
estime que les élites ne se parlent plus
qu'à elle-même qu'il n'y a plus une
conversation général qui traverse les
frontières de classe le monologue d
élite a fait muet la démocratie en
méritocratie elles réduisent désormais
la démocratie a l'opportunité
d'ascension sociale ce qui révèle
qu'elles conçoivent le peuple comme le
vivier de leur renouvellement or il
s'agit là d'une trahison de l'idéal
démocratique américain dans lequel la
société doit être homogénéiser par la
démocratisation de l'intelligence la
vision réductrice de la démocratie qu'on
les élites cette vision empêche
l'émergence des vertus citoyennes comme
l'autonomie la responsabilité l'esprit
d'initiative ou encore l'entr'aide
cherchant les racines de la révolte des
élites christopher lasch pointe du doigt
une nouvelle mentalité issus des
pratiques thérapeutiques au premier rang
desquels à la psychanalyse qui ont
fleuri au 20e siècle quel est le
problème avec ces nouvelles pratiques
elles ont donné à l'homme l'illusion
qu'il se maîtrise lui même et qu'il
maîtrise le monde et par conséquent que
le passé ne lui est d'aucune utilité
elles ont créé un vide spirituel en
ignorant les richesses spirituelles de
la tradition et de la religion
alors la vidéo vous a plu j'espère que
oui si vous ne l'avez pas fait je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez découvrir les
cinq secrets pour vous cultivez 10 fois
plus rapidement sans vous prendre la
tête inscrivez-vous simplement soit rang
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant haut à droite de la vidéo
souhaitent en cliquant sur celui qui est
dans la description de cette vidéo
croyez moi faites le et vous me
remercierez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]